- I'm sorry, do you mean "turn it up?"
And they go, "No, turn it down," she
goes, "so turn it up, then."
(laughter)
That's what I would do.
And then, I'd get fired, I'm sure.
- Yeah.
- Their bodies.
Your body is, it looks
fantastic, and it's--
- Yeah, take as many pictures as you can.
- Put your bathing suit on
and take a million pictures.
- Walk around in your bathing suit.
- Open your front camera
and be like, "Yeah."
- This is gonna sound crazy
to a person, if this person
is under fifty, you could
not do social media.
- Tina, no way.
- You could.
You could not do it.
- Tina, but how are people
gonna know that I had a party?
How do I see where people
are when I'm not with them
and how do they know where I've gone?
- How do I feel left out
about not being invited
to the thing they're at?
- Yes.
- Your body will find a way.
And also, just, everyone's
curating their life,
and it's like, if you're
really living your life,
you have no time for that.
- About ISIS, yeah.
Not about that.
- You should be worried about ISIS.
You should be worried about ISIS.
- The "Angry Teacher."
Just like, a lotta this.
Just like a lotta this, like,
"No, no, no, Mr. Wilson,
"Not today!"
That move.
"Not in my class!
"Sit down!"
- How do you get over it?
- Huh.
- Maybe just off it.
- Off it.
- [Amy] Just off-again it.
- [Voiceover] Yes.
- My mother-in-law, who I
lived, before I got married,
she said, "My only advice for marriage
"is don't fuss too much."
And she's a little southern lady.
And it's so true, it's
like, if something happens
and you're not really mad
about it, don't make yourself
mad about it because
you think you should be.
- My Nana, my Irish Nana, used to have
a lot of good little sayings.
One of them I like is, "Strangers should
"be a little strange," which
is just like, be a little bit
suspicious of people that
are too friendly to you
too soon, it's very Irish.
Or she would say, "You're
as busy as a one armed
"paper hanger," which was a funny--
- [Voiceover] Gosh, she
gave a lot of good advice.
- That's busy.
- Or, if you lost something, she'd say,
"Look where it is and you'll find it."
(laughter)
Which was infuriating.
That one was infuriating.